some of the things the president wants
to see is a reinstatement of the ban on
assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines he's also calling for stronger
background checks and wants congress to
end immunity that protects gun makers
from any liability some republicans
slamming the hearing as threatening the
second amendment but the president said
those rights are not absolute or
unlimited so here are the current gun
laws in nevada concealed carry is legal
with a permit we have red flag laws
which mean they can be used to suspend
concealed carry licenses for up to a
year and background checks required for
all private sales guns are banned in
schools airports and federal buildings
the ar-15 style rifle the most popular
rifle in america with about 20 million
while overall it is rarely used for
crime this type of gun has been used to
carry out some of our country's
deadliest mass shootings sasha loftis
spoke with local gun experts tonight who
shed some light on the importance of
education
brian this style of gun has been used in
nearly a dozen mass shootings since
2012. so we asked a local gun shop about
what makes it different from other
firearms
ar 15. the style of semi-automatic rifle
is known across america
this type of gun has been used in
multiple mass shootings in recent years
the semi-automatic version of that but
it's also the most popular in the nation
so what are these rifles used for and
how do they differ from other firearms
there's so many different uses for the
ar-15 that's why it's so prolific in our
our country here joshua nilsson owner of
dark horse tactical says with an ar-15
type gun you have to pull the trigger to
fire each shot and it automatically
reloads these are traveling at faster
speeds so they can tended to cause more
damage but a lot of that damage comes
down to the type of ammunition used and
any gun can lead to destruction there's
so much misconception about weapons and
owning weapons that's why chief security
adviser michael johnston says education
is crucial i don't care what weapon you
have if you do not train properly and
regularly it is a perishable skill he
and nilson urge anyone who is looking to
buy a weapon or just wants to learn more
about them this is called an ar-10 to
always turn to those with the most
knowledge the biggest thing is going to
be education
newly made machine guns and fully
automatic weapons were banned in the
united states in 1986 used ones can be
legally purchased but they are heavily
regulated bump stocks an attachment
which allows a semi-automatic rifle to
fire more quickly in a cycle were banned
in 2019 after their use in the one
october shooting denise
well